yeah and uh hopefully we will
bring something more than the
meaninglessness of that comment to this
segment as we go
speed round week eight and let's start
with that
jets chiefs game le'veon bell dumped by
the jets picked up by the chiefs played
last week six carries 39 yards against
the broncos le'veon bell will most
definitely
what versus the jets
ball out just because i'm sure that andy
reid is going to give him
plenty of opportunities to both carry
the ball and touch the ball in this game
i bet he gets 15 touches and look
there's
no question whatsoever clyde edward
solaire is the second
leading rusher in football right now but
i think this sunday is going to be
le'veon bell's day for kansas city
i agree with you the other way around
though the the the ultimate irony would
be
if he pulls a hamstring against the jets
because as we know there's nothing wrong
with his hamstrings all right after
lighting up the browns joe burrow will
what against the titans
i think joe burrow will play a good game
into the fourth quarter after getting
beat up like a ragdoll
um yeah look joe burrow has shown
uh over and over and over again that the
cincinnati bengals
are going to have a chance in every game
that he plays
so i don't think this will be a route i
think he'll play competitively
the bengals will score somewhere in the
20s and they'll lose the game but
they'll
be they'll be a scrappy cincinnati team
because
joe burrow makes them that right now
i think he will rack up another 300-yard
passing game he's on pace to break
andrew luck's rookie record in that
category all right
i would not know who ben denucci is if
he walked up to me on the street and
kicked me in the
face uh we're going to find out who ben
dinucci is because
here he is talking about his looming
first start sunday night football
against the eagles
for me this is a an opportunity of a
lifetime i think you know
as a rookie a seventh rounder i think
you know coming in you see dak and you
see andy at the top of the
top of the depth chart and you're like
hey there's there's you know there's
there's no chance that you know i'm
going to be on the field this year but
hey this is 2020 what else do you expect
here we are and
we gained my rookie year i've got a
chance to go out there on sunday night
football and
and do what i love to do so i couldn't
be happier and more excited
all right peter ben danucci and the
cowboys can beat the eagles if what
if ezekiel elliott shows up and is the
dominant back that
everybody says he is you know ezekiel
elliott has not
done well for the dallas cowboys uh
fumbling twice against uh
arizona to help lose that game and to
have an
awful performance i thought on sunday in
washington
this is the time where ezekiel elliott
needs to take a game on his shoulders
and to to do everything humanly possible
to try to grind out a win against all
odds
uh you know look there's no sense in
making fun of ben dinucci
and his and his history and james
madison and all that
it's just it's an unfortunate
circumstance for the dallas cowboys to
be playing their third string
quarterback
for those who say all the cowboys they
need to be better suited
they got to be better ready to survive
quarterback injuries
just stop who's got a third string
quarterback they're all ben denucci's
for me it's a very simple proposition
they will win on sunday night if the
message
sent by dumping don terry poe and daryl
worley actually takes in the locker room
if it doesn't they won't win after
lighting up the vikings in week one
aaron rodgers will do what this sunday
against the vikings at lambeau field
peter
light up the vikings in week eight um
now that he has devonte adams
and uh and he is getting very familiar
with the rest of his nobodies
including robert tanyan or tanyan
is it fanian or funyun mike and
and look he has made i i so admire what
aaron rodgers has done
this year because instead of coming in
all pissy during the season after they
take his success or
who everybody thinks his successor he
has come in and say hey guys
it's a sunny day let's go play football
you know i'm
i'm incredibly impressed with his
attitude
all season and i just think they're
gonna
they're gonna beat up the vikings on
sunday
i agree with you i think he will have
another big day and i'm surprised that
the spread is only seven points because
i just don't see the fight in this
vikings team
uh especially in light of the way they
started and coming off of the buy i
think they're just checking boxes until
they get to the end of the season
current state of the lions at three and
three
and who were buyers in the trade market
for everson griffin the current state of
the lions is what
i mean they're on they're basically
on the edge of a cliff like a lot of
teams are you know they're
and and i doubt anybody in that locker
room says hey we're playing for our
coaches job
i mean even though they are um i doubt
anybody
thinks that way the way i look at the
lions right now
is that i was really impressed
last week when they hung in hung in hung
in
got the break at the end and then
matthew stafford does what he's supposed
to do
have a clutch drive in the fourth
quarter which he's had many of
and to me i look at them and say
they're gonna they're gonna be a threat
to be a 500-ish team
because they have the capability and
they should have
the defense to be a 500 team even though
they haven't played at that level
so far this year and even if they should
lose on sunday to the colts and i
believe they will but who the hell knows
in any given nfl season
the schedule shakes out to nine and
seven
for the lions and with seven playoff
berths in the nfc and the afc this year
maybe that's enough to get them
in and the thing about this and i know
we gotta take a break
but the most fascinating thing about
that seventh spot peter
we are going to have sooner than later
a two seed that doesn't get a week off
but that does get a division rival
coming to town for the wild card round
and all bets are off when that happens
now i don't know that lions at packers
is going to scare the packers but
eventually you're going to get
one of these two seeds it gets knocked
wobbly
by a division rival that isn't
intimidated by them and that seven seed
is going to advance
i guess so but i still i think the most
interesting part of playoff seeding
this year is whether
some team makes the playoffs and only
plays 14 or 15 games
and you do the playoffs you do the
playoffs by winning percentage
instead of one loss record that's the
thing
and mike the nfl is not out of
any woods yet been great for eight weeks
relatively speaking
but there's a whole lot of trouble in
the last nine
weekends of the football season the
deepest darkest part of the forest is
still coming for the nfl with cold and
flu season and the thing that keeps high
level executives up at night
the prospect of teams falling out of
contention and the player is no longer
doing everything they need to do to
avoid the virus that is a very real
concern even though if the games aren't
played the players don't get paid
they're very concerned that the
non-contenders
will stop doing everything they have to
do to stay healthy and safe
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports